[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nous et à des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche dont intérêts de
leurs populations
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président tram va décider de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite c'est les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 13 octobre 2009
en france veillée d'armes ou plutôt
conseil de défense avant l'interview
d'emmanuel macron à la télévision demain
soir face à la dégradation de la
situation sanitaire de nouvelles mesures
sont à attendre pour réduire la
circulation du virus couvre-feu
confinement local télétravail est les
hypothèses ne manquent pas alors que
pour la première fois depuis le
printemps
le nombre de malades en réanimation a
dépassé la barre des 1500 suscitant les
pires craintes du monde hospitalier
[Musique]
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
2011 21 a débuté hier à l'assemblée s'il
prévoyait d'augmenter les taxes sur
l'essence l'an prochain à bercy assure
ce mardi qu'il n'y aura pas de
changement de la fiscalité mais la liste
des taxes ou éco taxe pourrait bien
s'allonger dans un avenir proche comme
pour l'électricité les jouets le
transport aérien avec bien sûr comme
conséquence pour les français une
augmentation des prix
au brésil jaillir bol son art au reprend
des couleurs le pays affiche un triste
bilan humain face au co vide mais le
président retrouve une cote de
popularité à plus de 40 % dans les
sondages contre -2 25% il ya quelques
mois
pas de confinement généralisée elle la
moitié de la population protégée par une
allocation
autant de facteurs qui expliquent cet
état de grâce pour un homme qui a
combattu le coronavirus
[Musique]
et on débute avec la situation sanitaire
en france est un point sur les derniers
chiffres la direction générale de la
santé annonce 12 1993 nouvelles
contaminations aux coville 19 ans 24
heures en hausse par rapport à mardi
dernier 117 personnes sont décédées dont
84 à l'hôpital et dans ce contexte de
dégradation sanitaire
que dire à emmanuel macron demain c'est
la question qui taraude les français
alors que les rumeurs de nouvelles
mesures de restriction s'amplifie au gré
des déclarations de membres du
gouvernement ont fait le point sur les
mesures potentielles avec thé au combat
c'est un exercice à haut risque qui
attend emmanuel macron face à la
recrudescence de l'épidémie de kovy 19
le président de la république doit
s'exprimer face aux français dans le
cadre d'une interview télévisée ce
mercredi aux alentours de 20 heures
l'inquiétude est vive au sommet de
l'état alors que les déclarations
rassurantes de l'été semble bien
lointaine
nous serons prêts nous avons à la fois
les stocks et les approvisionnements qui
sont sécurisées et nous avons
l'organisation au plus près du terrain
qui permettrait de faire face à une
recrudescence si elle était la preuve de
la gravité de la situation le premier
ministre n'a pas hésité lundi à parler
de deuxième vague
nous sommes dans une deuxième vague
forte j'appelle de façon extrêmement
clair à ce que nous nous mobilisons tous
et tous pour faire face à cette deuxième
vague
il ne peut plus y avoir de relâchement
rien ne doit être exclu quand on voit la
situation dans nos hôpitaux
face aux chiffres alarmants des
nouvelles contaminations et du taux de
remplissage des services de réanimation
la probabilité est forte de voir
s'imposer de nouvelles mesures de
restriction
celles ci peuvent se décliner en quatre
hypothèses
c'est la proposition qui fait le plus
débat une mesure moins radicale que le
confinement généralisée mais qui semble
difficilement applicable une éventualité
qui viserait principalement certaines
aires urbaines très touché par le virus
comme la région parisienne par exemple
un cordon sanitaire qui pose la question
du contrôle des allées et venues de
chacun et qui semble compliquée à mettre
en oeuvre sans oublier un impact
économique certain pour les zones
concernées
le couvre-feu une idée déjà soutenue par
l'allemagne qui va le mettre en place
dans différentes villes dont berlin
une initiative moins coûteuse
économiquement et socialement que la
france avait déjà appliqué en guyane au
moins de juin et juillet combinée à
d'autres mesures
l'opération avait été un succès avec une
diminution drastique de la propagation
du virus
autre possibilité renforcer les mesures
de restriction déjà mises en place
outre les bars et restaurants un certain
nombre de commerces lieux de loisirs et
de divertissements tels que les théâtres
où les salles de cinéma pourraient être
amenés à fermer afin de limiter le
nombre de contacts entre individus enfin
le scénario du pire pour le gouvernement
une éventualité que l'elysée veut à tout
prix éviter une situation que le pays a
connu pendant deux mois à partir du mois
de mars qui seraient potentiellement
catastrophiques pour l'économie mais
également sur le plan social
on le voit les possibilités sont
nombreuses sur la table des manuels
macron un choix qui a peut être déjà été
fait par le chef de l'état lors du
conseil de défense ce mardi des
déclarations attendues avec impatience
par les français mais également par les
soignants ces derniers craignent de
devoir bientôt choisir les patients à
soigner
si rien n'est fait aujourd'hui à des
annonces du président très attendue donc
surtout pour certaines professions
notamment médicale en première ligne
face au co vide ou bien encore par
d'autres confronté à des pertes
économiques abyssal à place à notre
décryptage pour analyser la situation
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre schwab
tellier un fermier aux urgences de
l'hôpital beaujon à clichy membres du
collectif inter urgence bonsoir avec
vous benjamin a marre professeur
d'histoire porte parole cgt 94 bonsoir
également pour décrypter cette actualité
thierry fontaine président de l'umih h
nuit c'est le principal syndicat des
établissements de nuit
bonsoir bienvenue à tous sur l'antenne
de rtl france alors face à la hausse des
cas l'exécutif s'apprête donc à prendre
de nouvelles mesures
la prise de parole des manuels macron de
demain soir on le disait et très attendu
on évoque un couvre-feu entre autres à
paris ou des récompenses de répons
finement dans certaines grandes villes
alors d'abord un petit tour de table si
j'ose dire qu'attendez-vous de la prise
de parole du président de la clarté
thiery fontaine on commence avec vous
oui en effet la profession attend un
petit peu de clarté de la logique des
des choses que le public peut comprendre
aujourd'hui on a changé de position
plusieurs fois le public c'est plus
c'est plus ça devient compliqué d'aller
dans un café ça devenait compliqué
d'aller au restaurant il ya des gestes
d'hyères d'aujourd'hui en termes de
communication c'est un petit peu floue
et même la progression elle même est
vrai de la logique aujourd'hui alors
même question pour vous venger maamar
cette prise de parole
elle doit elle va servir à quoi sachant
que pas de restrictions concernant les
écoles comme vient de l'annoncer jean
michel blanquer
la situation est sous contrôle précise
le ministre de l'éducation
vous attendez quoi vous benjamin a marre
de la prise de parole du président
demain
écoutez je vais vivre cette espérer je
veux bien mais alors franchement je
l'espère plus rien sur moi je me
souviens j'ai un peu de mémoire je pas
un poisson rouge avec 30 secondes de
mémoire tampon et je me souviens très
bien des grands discours avec des 10 des
tons comme ça très solennelle des
manuels macro
souvenez vous par exemple de toutes ces
histoires selon lesquelles il fallait
mieux payer les premiers de corvée bah
écoutez en l'occurrence allez donc
demander au premier de cordée dans le
nettoyage dans un certain nombre de
secteurs s'ils ont vu un euro de plus
sur leur fiche de paye de manière
générale je n'attends plus rien d'eux
gouvernement on va on va on va aller à
la pêche aux informations de manière
factuelle mais je n'attends rien
notamment en matière de cohérence vous
disiez à l'instant que selon le discours
de monsieur blanc caire tout allait bien
dans l'éducation va écouter dans le
monde de monsieur blanc caire peut-être
mais dans le monde réel celui dans
lequel mes collègues et moi nous
travaillons il n'en est rien et la
situation à l'école et je dirais je sais
pas quel adjectif quel qualificatif
utilisé
elle est désastreuse c'est le royaume de
l'opacité c'est le royaume de l'absence
de transparence c'est le royaume
également de l'incertitude et c'est le
royaume d'ubu roi ou raconte je dirais à
la cantonade ce que l'on veut mais qui
ne correspond pas au réel donc très
honnêtement je n'attends rien ce
gouvernement s'est montré désastreux
dans sa gestion sanitaire et à mon avis
il n'y aura rien de nouveau sous le
soleil
on va y revenir sur la situation dans
les écoles mais dans les hôpitaux à
paris qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez ou
pierre schwab
tellier la situation à ce qu'elle est
suffisamment grave pour envisager un
confinement par exemple alors
heureusement c'est pas moi de prendre
cette décision là et je laisserais
volontiers les gens qui ont un qui sont
responsables de salles à le faire en
tout cas la seule chose que je peux dire
c'est que si le confinement il ya en
tout cas ça sera certainement pas due à
une minorité qui ne respecteraient pas
les jeunes
les restes les gestes barrière pardon
mais bien l'incapacité du système
hospitalier français aujourd'hui
d'accueillir tout le monde lors de la
première vague on ne connaissait pas la
pathologie où on n'avait pas le matériel
on n'avait pas le capacitaire mais on a
eu des renforts qui ont permis de
ouvrir des lits et de pouvoir contrôler
à peu près cette première vague que très
clairement on n'a pas à gérer mais qu'on
a subies et là pour la deuxième vague
on a peut-être du matériel peut-être
qu'on a plus de protection et qu'on
connaît mieux la pathologie en tout cas
on n'a plus du tout personnel et il
reste encore lourd au problème des
capacités on a absolument pas de
capacité à l'heure actuelle pour
accueillir tout le monde à l'hôpital
vous vous attendez une déclaration du
président de la république sur ce sujet
là sur le sujet des effectifs dans le
milieu hospitalier
on attend on attend je pense que ça a
été clair le président de la république
par la boîte de oliveira a fait un ségur
de la santé et ceux ségur de la santé
même s'il se félicite de son importance
en continu la caisse de l'hôpital public
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui va être votée le 15
continuer à demander d 1 milliard
d'économies à l'hôpital public on
continue à supprimer des postes à
supprimer des lits malgré la crise du
corps un navire russe qui nous touche
alors le contexte économique se tend
également on a vu ces manifestations ce
matin enfin pierre pardon de forains des
autocaristes des vtc les intermittents
de la restauration
c'était ce matin sur le périph
pharisiens cette détresse sociale et
économique qui qui s'expriment celle de
ses scènes de nombreux français qu'on
voit là finalement benjamin a marre mais
bien évidemment vous savez je suis
convaincu que nous sommes assis sur un
baril de poudre
en réalité la situation sociale elle
était déjà très tendu avant le coc vite
vous souvenez que les gilet jaune
n'avait pas attendu effectivement locaux
vides pour se manifester voulez vous
avez aussi le souvenir des mobilisations
massives sur les retraites qui n'avait
pas attendu le coc vide
sauf que le coc vide a aggravé la
situation la confédération syndicale des
familles par exemple a effectivement
comment dire pointé le fait que le
je dirais 40% des sondés si je me
souviens bien déclaré avoir perdu
plusieurs centaines d'euros et avoir du
mal à faire face aux dépenses de
première nécessité les field avant les
files d'attentes devant le secours
populaire français par exemple se sont
considérablement allongés cette crise
vu qu vide c'est une crise salutaire et
c'est une crise sociale c'est à dire
qu'en réalité elles exacerbent les
tensions de classe et là quelle est la
réponse du gouvernement par rapport à ça
écoutez je suis le seul à avoir attendu
monsieur véran expliqué que désormais
chaque passage aux urgences qui ne se
solderait par une hospitalisation serait
facturée 2 2 à 2 18 euros
voilà la réponse du gouvernement et mon
interlocuteur est infirmier a tout à
fait raison de pointer comment dire la
situation est scandaleuse
pendant des mois on nous a expliqué
pendant que vides emmanuel macron le
premier la nécessité de se renouveler
nous avait-il dit moi le premier at il
rajouté
et donc on pouvait s'imaginer que le
fait que l'hôpital public était à deux
doigts de craquer pendant la crise due
qu'au guide et bien on avait tiré les
leçons que nenni rien du tout et on en
est encore à fermer des lits et on en
est encore effectivement à faire des
chèques en blanc aux grandes entreprises
du cac 40
et rien dans le plan de relance rien sur
le pouvoir d'achat rien sur les salaires
rien effectivement sur les minimas
sociaux je rappelle que ce gouvernement
a refusé de revaloriser le rsa c'est ça
la réalité nous sommes face à des gens
qui sont des apprentis sorciers et ses
apprentis sorciers ils dansent sur un
baril baril de poudre
le 15 octobre il va y avoir une grande
manifestation dans la santé mais le 17
octobre
samedi plusieurs organisations de la cgt
dont la mienne unions départementales
cgt du val de marne avec la fédération
des services publics la fédération du
commerce les plus gros union
départementale de la cgt ont appelé à
une marche pour la dignité pour l'emploi
mais y avoir du monde et c'est
l'important c'est très important de
faire entendre la voix de la colère
sociale
alors justement thierry fontaine vous
faisiez partie des manifestants ce matin
sur le périphérique lyonnais vous êtes
patron de boîte de nuit à lyon quelle
est votre situation pour qu'on comprenne
bien aujourd'hui la situation la
situation aujourd'hui des entrepreneurs
en france et notamment des boîtes de
nuit qui
enfermés depuis sept mois elle est
plutôt dramatique puisque on a eu des
promesses beaucoup n'ont pas touché
beaucoup voient leur outil de travail
disparaître on a déjà 80 de dépôt de
bilan c'est autant de salariés qui vont
se retrouver sans emploi
on s'oriente à 300 dépôt de bilan à la
fin de l'année donc j'imagine est ce que
ça va faire en terme d'emploi c'est
souvent des jeunes et d'un autre côté on
n'a aucune rémunération c'est à dire que
nous ont parlé de revers les assure du
rsa on est pour un complètement mais non
la même pas c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
on vit avec zéro euro depuis le 14 mars
qui est capable en france de vivre avec
pas un euro depuis une période aussi
longue il ya beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise qui ont des enfants qui
doivent scolarisés ils doivent les
nourrir ils doivent les chauffer
aujourd'hui doit faire un toit on doit
pouvoir chauffer il ya un minimum
je sais que beaucoup de français sont
dans la détresse
bien sûr que ça nous touche tous les
jours mais là on est en train de
rajouter à la pauvreté
toute une profession parce qu'on refuse
de lui parler on refuse de trouver des
protocoles des possibilités de sortie de
cette crise et on a eu beaucoup de
promesses en effet mais moi j'ai
beaucoup de professionnels de l'autre
côté qui me disent ce ne sont que des
promesses
on n'a pas touché parce que dans les
décrets ya toujours une petite virgule
la technocratie fait que aujourd'hui
quand on arrive au bout on n'a pas que
pensent eux l'infirmier aux urgences de
toute cette situation comment faire pour
maintenir une activité économique
finalement sang coulait l'hôpital de
l'autre côté pierre schwab tellier moi
personnellement ça fait un an et demi
qu'on en mobilisation on n'a pas attendu
le coronavirus pour dénoncer la
situation dans les hôpitaux qui nous
semblait déjà alarmante avant la crise
la crise n'a fait que révéler très
clairement où en jour ce qu'on disait
depuis le début qu'on n'a pas les moyens
d'accueillir tout le monde aujourd'hui
les choix politiques qui ont été faits
on a eu cinq mois pour se préparer les
choix politiques qui ont été faits n'ont
pas été faits en faveur de l'hôpital
très clairement et on a on n'a pas
d'amélioration en termes de capacité
donc oui c'est oui donc comme me disait
le collègue de la cgt le problème c'est
que l'état comme il comme il gère une
entreprise comme l'hôpital il n'a pas
les moyens de répondre à la demande il
va donc elle va donc essayer de diminuer
cette demande en faisant payer l'entrée
en faisant payer les urgences alors
après il ya un gros amalgame montant par
les montants sur ce forfait est urgence
entre la nécessité d'hospitalisation et
la nécessité de soins qui sont deux
choses totalement différentes et qui
sont un petit peu insultante en termes
de professionnels d urgence puisque
c'est une minorité de patients qui sont
sûrs qu'ils sont hospitalisés mais les
autres patients nécessite quand même des
soins qu'on s'est un petit peu insultant
envers nous de nous dire que on s'occupe
de gens qui n'ont pas besoin en gros de
venir à l'hôpital donc voilà mais non là
l'état continue ça les accords du ségur
de la santé on en a beaucoup parlé dans
les faits ce que voulez vous voyez vous
les voyez les milliards qui ont été
posées le réduire
on parle on parle de 3 on se fixe sur
trois versants il ya trente trois
mesures dans le secteur de la santé dont
la remise en cause des 35 heures dont la
mise en place de 11 heures de repos
entre deux journées travaillées au lieu
de 12 heures réglementaires
parce qu'on veut favoriser le 12 heures
à l'hôpital parce que c'est plus simple
parce que ça permet de le ramener plus
de monde mais voilà mais c'est ça les
mesures du seigneur mais en réalité
elles n'auront convaincu très clairement
que les organisations syndicales
signataires
les professionnels eux ils ont répondu
ils sont en train de démissionner en
masse 40% des infirmes et veulent
changer de métier d'après la dernière
enquête de l'ordre national des
infirmiers
elle est là la réponse je vous propose
maintenant de s'arrêter sur les
réactions politiques 1 24 heures avant
la prise de parole des manuels macron
est les commentaires sont assez acerbe
comme celui vous allez le voir de la
patronne du rassemblement national de
marine le pen regarder ce qui me frappe
depuis le début de cette épidémie
c'est l'absence totale d'anticipation de
la part du gouvernement
où est le plan de gestion de crise on
pouvait éventuellement leur pardonner
pour la première vague
c'est impardonnable pour la seconde
alors absence totale d'anticipation de
la part
gouvernement la critique est facile
danger maamar où vous en partager le
constat
moi j'attends pas l'extrême droite
crypto fasciste pour faire des constats
qui sont factuels
soyons très clairs oui effectivement je
pense que n'importe qui qui n'a pas un
espace vide entre les deux oreilles se
rend bien compte que ce gouvernement est
qu'une brochette de pieds nickelés qui
effectivement ne fonctionne qu'à
l'exercice de qom voilà si on avait des
hommes d'état quel que soit leur bord
politique d'ailleurs si on avait des
gens qui au delà des accents et des
trémolos dans la voix
comment dire prenait la situation à
comment dire à sa juste home
eh bien on aurait eu des des décisions
je dirais des grandes décisions fortes
qui ne finalement ne remue pas comme une
girouette vient donc on peut partir
quand même juste des chiffres de santé
publique france puisque le gouvernement
se fissure santé publique france qu'est
ce qu'on vous dit et bien que entre les
écoles et les entreprises
on a autour de 60% des clusters voilà et
que les rassemblements publics de
personnes
c'est autour de 8% des clusters donc à
force de je crois que ces flics qui
lequel deux des autres interlocuteurs a
pointé le fait que effectivement ont
stigmatisé comme ça les rassemblements
publics et privés dans les bars etc
alors qu'en réalité le problème ah si on
regarde les chiffres de santé public
français a priori c'est là dessus que le
gouvernement seconde on a à l'école et
dans les entreprises là l'ultrafrais la
grande majorité des clusters voix est
derrière vous l'avez dit vous-même
monsieur oui monsieur blanc qu'elle nous
dit tout va bien circulez ya rien à voir
et donc on a un vrai souci on a un vrai
problème effectivement de cohérence vous
avez vu comme moi dans n'importe quelle
grande ville en france l'accueil
l'interminable que nous avons eu au
moment devant les laboratoires sur la
question des tests parce que la question
des tests elle a été finalement aussi
lamentablement gérer que la question des
masques voilà donc on a effectivement
une gigantesque impréparation alors
critique également du numéro deux de la
france insoumise cette fois de rien qu'à
tenace regarder quand on voit qu'on ne
peut plus aller au restaurant après 22
heures mais qu'on peut continuer à
s'entasser
les matins dans les transports en commun
en termes de circulation de l'épidémie
c'est peut-être plus dangereux que des
restaurants dans lesquels des protocoles
sanitaires strictes sont appliquées
alors c'est vrai qu'on a parfois du mal
à saisir les différents protocoles
sanitaires qui existent un peu partout
qu'en pense le professionnel de santé
pierre tellier vous savez on a on a on a
eu cette première vague à l'origine on
nous a dit quand même qu'il fallait pas
porter de masque
donc je me méfie depuis le début des
protocoles sanitaires y compris pendant
la première vague dans les hôpitaux qui
ont été en fonction de la pénurie ou de
l'accès aux en ce moment donc là
maintenant qu'on en a des masses que
tout le monde doit emporter ce
obligatoire sinon c'est la mode
donc voilà je n'ai pas trop d'avis là
dessus c'est pour moi c'est je veux dire
c'est à presse et de la communication
c'est voilà faut faire quelque chose
pour pas être condamnée à ne rien avoir
fait mais on soit le gros problème pour
moi c'est dans l'hôpital on n'a pas les
capacités pour accueillir tout le monde
donc très clairement quoi qu'il fasse
tant qu'ils remettront pas des lits et
des moyens à l'hôpital public pour
accueillir de façon optimale la
population sera toujours confronté à ce
genre de choix et on pourra choisir des
responsables vous mettre des boucs
émissaires sur les étudiants ça changera
pas le problème il vous le professionnel
de la nuit ça vous irrite qu'on voyait
ses métros bondés et puis ces bars
fermés à partir de 22h dans le même
temps alors oui bien sûr que ça mérite
je vais rejoindre je vais pas rentrer
mois sur le sujet médical parce que je
ne suis pas médecin du tout et je veux
surtout pas essayer de le devenir
en effet il ya des mesures et des
protocoles qui sont stupides on va dîner
en couple dans un restaurant
on est obligé de garder son masque
jusqu'à l'arrivée du premier plat le
remettre entre deux plats l'ont enlevé
après quand on sort on rentre dans la
même voiture on rentre dans le même
foyer on va dormir dans le pipeline que
là on échoue on comprend pas mais ce
qu'on comprend surtout c'est que plus on
ferme des commerces puis on ferme des
bars puis on ferme des restaurants qui
sont visibles ou l'opinion publique et
voit tous les jours voit les protocoles
voit ce qui est appliqué ou des
professionnels sont comme responsable et
raisonnable et font appliquer ces
protocoles
plus on ferme ces établissements plus au
crès une prohibition on crée on fait une
fête souterraine qui en plus pour les
jeunes et plutôt excitante
on fait la fête ses 21 interdit ça
rajoute quelque part un attrait à cette
fête et on se rend compte que dans ces
rassemblements
il ya beaucoup plus de contamination que
dans les bars ils sont multipliées par 3
par quatre par 5
on a vu alors je stigmatise pas du tout
les jeunes au contraire on n'a qu'une
fois 18 ans dans sa vie ces jeunes
pendant quatre points la répéter en
boucle qu'il ne craignait rien qu'il ne
craignait absolument rien aujourd'hui
vous leur demander d'être en prison non
c'est pas possible
ces jeunes où vous les mettez dans des
commerces avec des professionnels qui
les encadre et on arrive à minima on
vous dit pas qu'il rakovic 0 mais qu'est
ce qu'il vaut mieux qu'ils aient 4 ou 5
4 e vide dans un bar dans une soirée où
quand on est 70 à 80 au final dans un
regroupement parce qu'ils sont retrouvés
à une centaine dans un appartement qui
on te report ou contenir 10 ils sont su
remplacer ya pas de ventilation pas de
gestes barrières pas de masque parce que
tout le monde se sent invincible et une
date ce qui est logique on leur a arrêté
1 et au final ça on n'a pas quatre
contamination mais en nombre à 50 60
ces 55 potentiellement vont contaminer
des plus anciens et c'est ça qui va
créer une charge à l'hôpital
si la méthode du gouvernement avait été
la bonne je pense pas qu'aujourd'hui on
naviguerait entre 12 et 20 mille cas
positifs testé par jour je pense qu'on
s'est plutôt peut-être à trois quatre
cinq mille mais là je pense que c'est
beaucoup
si en effet la logique du gouvernement
était d'arriver à la et ben c'est une
réussite
s'il voulait continuer à maintenir un
qu'ovide son capital soit surchargé
alors on peut clairement dire que c'est
un échec
clairement alors pour finir il noise
deux minutes ce chiffre également 45 %
des salariés se sentent plus fatigués
physiquement et psychologiquement
qu'avant la crise du coc vide à c'est le
résultat d'une enquête ifop 1 publié ce
mardi on va sortir dans quel état tu
cette crise benjamin a marre alors là
moi je suis extrêmement optimiste je
vous le dis ce sont notre société était
une société en tension avant le coc vide
le coc vide et la gestion calamiteuse du
gouvernement à exacerber cette situation
moi je à votre question est générale
mais moi je vais juste là concentrée sur
mes collègues les enseignants entre eux
effectivement
le comment dire la communication et la
gestion très aléatoire du ministre et la
fatigue que provoque le fait de faire
cours en permanence avec des masques
avec des élèves qui fatalement sont
moins disponibles et bien moi mais mes
collègues me disent que quand ils
rentrent chez eux
il tombe de sommeil ils sont épuisés
c'est extrêmement compliqué et ce qui va
là pour les enseignants est valable pour
beaucoup de professions on a finalement
eu une incertitude une inquiétude
sanitaire qui se double d'une inquiétude
sociale enfin me rappelle quand même
hein là on est les premiers les
prévisions de l'unedic c'est un million
d'emplois détruits d'ici la fin de
l'année
ça fait lourd ça fait lourd et quand on
a en face un gouvernement aussi
finalement aussi inconsistant et bien
j'ai l'impression qu'on a tous les
ingrédients pour un cocktail explosif et
vous les soignants dans quel état pour
affronter cette seconde vague écoutait
les soignants quand je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure on a une dernière il ya eu une
heure une enquête qui a montré qu'il
avait 40 % des infirmiers qui voulaient
carrément changer de métier on a
un gros problème quand on s'appelle en
termes de nombre de personnels beaucoup
de départs beaucoup de personnes qui
refusent de refaire du coc vide parce
que c'est des sacrifices c'est pour
certains ça a été de ne plus voir ses
enfants pendant près de deux mois donc
c'est quand même un sacré sacrifices
n'ont en réalité où on est toujours au
même point c'est à dire c'est que
l'hôpital public paye la gestion
économique de ces dix dernières années
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on est tous en
france et qu'il ya beaucoup de personnel
hospitalier dans la fonction publique
hospitalière qui sont proches de la
dépression proche du burn out
les enquêtes de santé au travail le
montre mais en même temps l'hôpital
public est incapable d'y répondre
simplement parce qu'on a plus de
médecins du travail
on n'a plus du tout de visite de
médecins du travail ça fait neuf ans je
travaille de nuit j'ai jamais faite
visite de la médecine du travail
on est incapable d'avoir un suivi
quelconque sur les prés salés
l'hospitalier parce que voilà c'est au
pire et s'en vont merci à tous les trois
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
direct sur rtl france merci pierre choix
de tellier infirmier aux urgences de
l'hôpital beaujon à clichy membres du
collectif interurbain ans mercy avoue
benjamin amar porte parole cgt 94
merci à vous thierry fontaine président
de l'uem ih nuit c'est le principal
syndicat des établissements de nuit
restez avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
le projet de loi de finances 2010 21 son
examen a débuté hier à l'assemblée s'il
prévoyait d'augmenter les taxes sur
l'essence l'an prochain bercy assure ce
mardi qu'il n'y aura pas de changement
et puis direction ensuite le brésil la
cote de popularité déjà erbol sauna roi
ne cesse d'augmenter en dépit en dépit
d'un bilan sanitaire déplorable avec un
pays qui dépasse les 5 millions de
contaminés a tout de suite sur rt france
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens du mans
voyez aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale
malgré des tensions
à la surface de nos terres
[Musique]
on est sur des bourses qui se porte bien
alors qu'on sait très bien que
l'économie en général est très très très
très loin derrière les actions ne sont
plus le reflet d'une activité humaine
ce sont de purs objets mathématiques est
ce que cette crise est liée au crédit
d'appel a accentué ce décalage entre
l'économie réelle et les marchés
boursiers sont déconnectés depuis déjà
un bon moment c'est depuis que les
banques centrales ont une politique
d'impression monétaire et ses fameux
quantitative easing
les gérants sont simplement là comme des
joueurs de casino pour attribuer le cash
dont il dispose à bas le risque que ça
c'est que à un moment on se bat comme
dans les dessins animés ou se réveille
et s'aperçoit qu'on est au dessus du lit
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche dont intérêts de
leurs populations
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française alors que mercredi soir
emmanuel macron pourrait annoncer de
nouvelles mesures restrictives pour
lutter contre l'épidémie de kobe 19 la
méthode du confinement connaître une
grande vague de critiques à travers le
monde lit la femme ouzou le confinement
ne peut pas être le moyen premier de
lutte contre le virus
le constat est sans appel et il viande
de l'envoyé spécial de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
oco vite 19 les confinements n'ont
qu'une seule conséquence que vous ne
devez jamais minimiser c'est de rendre
les pauvres beaucoup plus pauvres
rien qu'en france bridgestone à béthune
chapelle darblay à grand-couronne
bénéteau à noirmoutier schneider
electric si mr la cnec depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire les plans sociaux
se succèdent pas un jour ou presque sans
l' annonce d'une nouvelle fermeture
d'une usine 32 sites au total et près de
5000 salariés sur le carreau
l'exécutif semble vouloir à tout prix
éviter en confinement général mais il
pourrait être tenté par les solutions de
confinement localisés dont l'espace ou
dans le temps nous avons pris les
décisions qui s'imposaient nous
continuons de le prendre elles sont
déclinées territorialement
parce que c'est comme ça qu'il faut
faire l'envoyé spécial de l'om est ce
délégué au comité 19 appelle plutôt à
développer de meilleurs systèmes pour
lutter contre le corona les russes du
côté des scientifiques ont aimé les
mêmes doutes quant à la solution du
confinement
les personnes âgées et en mille fois
plus susceptibles de mourir de lakovic
19 que les personnes plus jeunes une
approche stratifié parages pourrait
permettre de concentrer les ressources
sur les patients plus âgés et à haut
risque tout en permettant à des
personnes plus jeunes et en meilleure
santé d'aller à l'école et de garder les
entreprises ouvertes à ce jour là les
confinements ont de manière générale
montré une capacité certaine à ralentir
l'épidémie a minima temporairement mais
elles n'ont pas empêché le rebond de
cette dernière en france une fois l'été
passé
de plus selon plusieurs scientifiques le
remède serait pire que le mal
l'aube le campement avec une arme de
destruction massive et il est évident
les conséquences sociales économiques
sont sans aucune comparaison avec le
problème sanitaire ce qui semble être en
cause dans la capacité des pays
européens à lutter contre le virus c'est
l'affaiblissement de nos systèmes de
santé à l'exception de l'allemagne
plutôt qu une malchance ou une fatalité
une hypothèse confirmée par cette
récente étude du lancet qui a comparé
les mesures prises en asie et en europe
lors de la première vague en europe
plus d'une décennie de mesures
d'austérité ont considérablement
affaibli les systèmes de santé et la
protection sociale
en revanche des épidémies majeures ont
poussé de nombreux pays asiatiques à
investir dans la construction
d'infrastructures bien équipé pour faire
face à la prochaine épidémie avec plus
de moyens plus de personnel et plus de
lits de réanimation nous aurions sans
doute pu éviter le confinement
ce n'est pas le choix qui a été fait par
nos dirigeants la question aujourd'hui
alors que tous les indicateurs sont au
rouge est de savoir si l'état a
véritablement tirer les leçons de la
première vague et on en vient au projet
de loi de finances 2011 21 son examen a
débuté hier à l'assemblée s'il prévoyait
d'augmenter les taxes sur l'essence sur
l'an prochain bercy assure ce mardi
qu'il n'y aura pas de changement de la
fiscalité mais la liste des taxes ou éco
taxe pourrait bien s'allonger dans un
avenir proche comme pour l'électricité
les jouets les transports aériens en
attendant les répercussions sur les prix
pour en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain c'est un autre rubrique l édito
[Musique]
alexis poulain merci à d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors le projet
de loi de finances pas d'augmentation de
taxes sur l'essence assure merci pour
autant la tentation reste telle grande
oui bruno le maire a rassuré tout le
monde dans ce débat sur le projet de loi
de finances 2010 21 en disant qu'il n'y
aura pas bien pas de nouvelle taxe que
le gouvernement restait sur cette ligne
mais la tentation est grande de trouver
des moyens pour trouver des recettes
pour l'état et c'est sûr que tout a
commencé avec cette idée de la taxe sur
les carburants
en revenant avec un centime chaque année
jusqu'en 2022 2023
les taxes sur le carburant on s'en
rappelle c'est la taxe carbone c'est le
début du mouvement des gilet jaune
pourquoi vouloir à tout prix remettre
sur la table cette idée qu'ils avaient
bien mis dans la rue tous ces français
qui avaient du mal à finir le mois
donc fin de non recevoir le gouvernement
recule mais néanmoins cherche de
nouvelles idées pour taxer les français
et il ya cette idée qui vient de 40
députés de la majorité en marche qui
proposerait une redevance pour tous y
compris ceux qui n'ont pas de poste de
télévision à la maison puisque
aujourd'hui on peut regarder la
télévision sur différents supports
d'écran et donc la télévision n'est plus
le seul objet qui ferait qu' il y aurait
la redevance dont on voit bien qu'en
termes d'aventis vite et d'impôts de
taxes nouvelles on peut faire confiance
au gouvernement il va falloir être
extrêmement vigilant pour voir ce qui
est pas de nouvelles taxes qui viennent
se faufiler dans ce projet de loi de
finances sur les jouets on en parlait
taxe plastique taxe sur les transports
aériens taxe sur d'autres carburants
taxe bien sûr augmentation des prix du
gaz de l'électricité à partir de janvier
ou plus tard donc restons vigilants
parce que malgré les promesses
peut-être que le gouvernement va
redoubler d'inventivité pour trouver des
moyens quand même de taxer les français
et de remplir les caisses de l'état
justement quelles sont les pistes qui
pourraient être envisagées par le
gouvernement
alors les pistes envisagées par le
gouvernement c'est clair on ne touchera
pas à l' isf
on ne revient pas sur l'impôt il faut de
la stabilité fiscale notamment pour les
plus riches
même si pourtant beaucoup d'économistes
sont en train de militer pour que les
riches payent leur part parce que
comme vous le disiez dans le sujet
précédent le confinement à faire entrer
dans la pauvreté plus d'un million de
français qui étaient déjà dans la
précarité
donc pas de retour sur ce set isf ni sur
la baisse d'impôts de production rien de
tout ça alors peut-être que le
gouvernement attend une taxe européenne
sur les gaffes à qui est le serpent de
mer dont on parlait cet été et qui va
peut être venir une taxe aussi à
l'apport peut-être des mesures
protectionnistes aux frontières
européennes qui pourraient remplir les
caisses de l'état
et puis il ya pourtant des ong qui l ont
des idées c'est greenpeace qui ce matin
proposait une taxe écologique pour les
plus riches pour les plus hauts revenus
parce que c'est eux qui ont un mode de
vie qui polluent le plus et donc proposé
aux plus riches de payer en fonction de
leurs achats de leur transport
parce que c'est eux qui ont la plus
grosse trace carbone et donc pourquoi
pas retrouver les sf mais écologique
paliès f tout court donc les idées ne
manquent pas mais le gouvernement lui ne
veut pas retourner retaxer les
entreprises ou les plus hauts revenus et
pourtant ce n'est pas il y aura un
besoin
compte tenu de l'extrême pauvreté qui
est galopante suite au confinement et la
crise du coronavirus et la question de
la dette alors oui alors bruno le maire
évidemment on parle de ce plan de
relance 1 200 milliards de la dette
puisque la dette est maintenant
totalement laissé libre par ce qu'il
faut à tout prix relancer l'économie la
soutenir faire en sorte que les
faillites ne soit pas trop nombreuses et
donc 2042c la date annoncée par bruno le
maire pour le remboursement total de la
dette qu'ovide si tout va bien ça
voudrait dire que d'ici à 2040 de la
croissance devrait être au rendez vous
et ne devrait pas y avoir de nouvelle
crise financière ou autre
donc autant dire que c'est quand même
parier sur la comète de très très loin
et puis il ya les prévisions de
croissance alors elles sont bonnes
de la part du fmi et d'autres pour pour
la reprise mais encore une fois très peu
de visibilité sur cette dette est tous
les thuriféraires de la dette que ce
soit le gouverneur de la banque de
france françois villeroy de galhau que
ce soit pierre moscovici que ce soit
christine lagarde à la bce tous sont
d'accord il va falloir la rembourser
cette dette coûte que coûte malgré là
encore des idées novateur de la part
d'économistes qui propose une annulation
de la dette détenue par les banques
centrales pour éviter justement
et bien c'est cette inflation galopante
de la dette et le prix qu'ils en aient à
payer sur le coût de cette dette comparé
au service public parce que aujourd'hui
la question qui se pose c'est à quoi
vont servir ces milliards des plans de
relance si c'est uniquement pour
soutenir une bulle financière
il faudrait penser planification il
faudrait penser soutien aux petites
entreprises soutien aux ménages c'est ce
que fait le japon par exemple ou
l'allemagne en france on a choisi de
soutenir d'abord les entreprises
on verra ensuite et cette dette on la
laisse courir jusqu'en 2042
c'est l'idée de bruno le maire mais là
encore comme je le disais tout dépend du
taux de croissance tout dépend de la
capacité qu'a la france à rembourser
alors la france est un pays qui jusqu'à
présent va bien qui a une bonne note
vis-à-vis des agences de notation et
donc la dette française est un produit
financier qui marche bien sur les
marchés internationaux donc pas trop de
risque de ne pas pouvoir rembourser
cette dette le problème c'est les taux
d'intérêt de cette dette qui même si
aujourd'hui ils sont très bas grâce à
l'action de la bce
grâce à l'euro également pour s envoler
néanmoins parce que on n'arrête pas de
s'embêter parce que rien ne dit que les
taux de croissance vont revenir à ce
qu'ils étaient avant que vide rapidement
rien ne dit que les nombreuses faillites
ne vont pas impacter également les
banques qui elles aussi pourrait subir
une faillite systémique donc tout repose
sur un bon vouloir beaucoup d'optimisme
en disant que ce plan de relance ses
plans de relance européens cumulé vont
aider à soutenir l'économie vont aider à
éviter un maximum de faillite et donc
cette dette
eh bien elle reste de qualité et elle ne
va pas se détériorer sur les marchés
financiers bon ça c'est un pari on verra
dans les années qui viennent
merci beaucoup à alexis poulain
éditorialistes c'était notre rubrique
l'édito
x et direction le brésil à présent le
deuxième pays le plus durement touché
par le col vide avec plus de cent
cinquante mille morts et pourtant en
dépit des critiques le gouvernement du
président jacques bolson arrow retrouve
sa popularité qu'il avait lors de son
élection
les explications avec françois disque et
nietzsche ambiance détendue ce samedi
dans les rues de la station balnéaire de
guaruja dans l'état de sao paulo après
une petite escapade à moto jaillir ball
sonar au se prête au jeu des selphy avec
quelques partisans et le président
brésilien de quoi être décontracté
crédité de moins de 30% d'opinions
favorables en décembre dernier il
atteint désormais plus de 40% soit le
plus fort taux d'opinions favorables
depuis le début de son mandat une
popularité à la hausse constatée
notamment chez les brésiliens les plus
pauvres qui ont touché d'avril à août
une allocation mensuelle de 100 euros
pour faire face à la pandémie de commis
19 une allocation prolongé jusqu'en
décembre mais réduite de moitié par
jaillir ball sonar au début septembre
sans pour autant que cela n'entame sa
confiance
combien on désherbe le montant précédent
1 600 reais et beaucoup pour s'équiper
et même si la nouvelle sonne n'est pas
suffisante pour tous les besoins en
réalité et l'aide critiquée pour sa
gestion du coronavirus le chef de l'état
pourtant réussi à tirer son épingle du
jeu en comprenant la réalité du pays
dans lequel il vit pas de confinement
généralisée mise en place une solution
impensable pour le brésil où l'essentiel
de la population travaillent dans les
secteurs informels et ce malgré un bilan
coville parmi les pires de la planète
avec plus de cent cinquante mille morts
jr ball sonara d'ailleurs lui même était
malade en juillet dernier parfaitement
remuant
cet épisode a renforcé son image et son
aura aux allures prophétique auprès d'un
peuple très religieux lui qui pour
rappel avait été poignardé en septembre
2018 en pleine campagne présidentielle
si vous êtes rap locaux vides un jour ne
vous inquiétez pas nous essayons de
l'éviter vous savez j'ai 65 ans je n'ai
rien senti
même pas une petite grippe absolument
rien du tout à deux ans des élections
présidentielles une réélection de
jacques bolson arrow est donc plus que
probable
mais en deux ans tout peut changer
d'autant que la situation économique du
brésil est préoccupante
le déficit des finances publiques a
quintuplé et le taux de chômage a
atteint le niveau record des 13,8 pour
ça et pour en parler nous sommes avec
driss galy spécialiste en relations
internationales
driss galy bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
le disait malgré un pays très durement
touchée par le coni gianni molinaro
compte 40% d'opinions favorables alors
qu'il était à 25% avant la crise
finalement son choix de ne pas confiner
le pays lui est il était favorable
je pense bon soir d'abord je pense que
oui puisque il a ça lui a permis de
parler à des classes populaires qui
réellement ont senti dans leur chair
prix 1 le prix d'une blocage du blocage
de l'économie parce que le brésil n'a
pas confiné mais les mairies n'ont pas
suivi au sonar où j'habite açores par où
la mairie sur par l'eau qui est plutôt
au centre gauche a fait une sorte de
blocage de l'économie en fermant les
bars on les autorisons ouvrir pendant
quelques heures
les écoles sont encore fermées donc on
dit que le brésil n'a pas confiné en
fait il ya eu beaucoup d' entrave à la
circulation et les plus les gens qui lui
donne un fromage et des femmes de ménage
les gardiens les vigiles sa pays qu'il
est passionné le cas beaucoup de vigiles
les gens qui travaillent dans les
supermarchés ils ont vu qu'ils ont perdu
leur job et ce matin je suis venu en
avant fo supermarché ce que j'avais mais
je n'ai jamais vu en dix ans préside
l'ue
d'entente mais 20 30 personnes pour
remettre des cv pour gagner un smic qui
aussi autour de même pas 200 250 euros
une file d'attenté pour être dans un
supermarché
c'est dire la détresse de ce peuple
effectivement ball standard a été un des
rares à leur dire votre jeu m'intéresse
ou pas quotidien et je préfère que vous
vous un ennemi que vous exposez au
provident que mourir de faim etc les
gens ça s'apprend par s'apprend pas chez
les classes moyennes supérieures qui
travaillent en remote office santé de
travail qui sont assurés d'avoir un
salaire par les multinationales
brésiliennes ou internationale mais chez
le peuple qui est le plus nombreux face
helicopters qui ont bas de la pyramide
et qui est le plus nombreux donc d'un
point de vue électoral qui est très
important se concentrant à à marquer des
points alors il ya eu aussi un ce
versement d'une aide financière de 100 à
200 euros aux plus pauvres
est-ce que là aussi ça a permis de
limiter la crise est-ce que d'autres
facteurs ont permis ce rebond de
popularité du président brésilien
alors le prophète il y a deux brésil
d'un point de vue électoral il ya le
brésil de l'accent paulo rio où se passe
l'économie des résidents se passe la vie
on va dire économique dans ce pays
ce pack sera votée ball son art au même
chez les plus pour peut-être j'allais
dire même surtout chez les plus pauvres
pour des raisons évangéliques pour des
raisons de lutte contre l'insécurité
savez c'est comme en france c'est les
plus pauvres qui sont massacrés et les
riches normalement ils vivent dans des
ghettos parisien où il
ils ont tendance à excuser télé les
criminels auraient six à peu près pareil
donc les pauvres deux des axes de la
criée au sort par l'eau votée pour cela
ceux de lax d'une horde est c'est à dire
les états où on va en vacances d'adhérer
fortaleza fin de l'année aux grains de
donneurs qu elle ait el bahia qui sont
des êtres très peuplées bien 30% des
pays bien 15% du pid 30% du brésil
annonce en ce sens des états faibles
pauvre c est à la voter majoritairement
lula parce que c'était la gauche c'était
le petit père du peuple et nous la
distribuer la baule sa famille
une invocation permanente une sorte de
rsa et la mort son art aux grassois
cause du provident
il aura mis une usine saab et maxi doit
émerger soeur l'aide d'urgence et et
malheureusement c'est dommage pour la
démocratie mais ce ces gens là ont
commencé à porter par d'ambon sonar pour
le sauveur ils sont en train de
remplacer l'icône de lula celle que nous
adorons france parce qu'il est de gauche
par l'icône de bolton arrow qui
distribue les 100 euros par mois
je dis que c'est dommage moi démocratie
parce que c'est ça veut dire qu'on se
sent des voix qu'on achète
mais voilà c'était dans la poche de
votre question là il en train de gagner
lord est et nordey ses 30% population
brésilienne
donc effectivement pour une réélection
il est beaucoup moins enfin ça s'annonce
pas trop vous parler également de foire
on sait que cette notion de fois elle
est très présente au brésil
girbaud le scénario a survécu à une
attaque au couteau puis au coville est
ce que le président brésilien son parent
du religieux comme ressort pour unir son
peuple autour de lui disons que le il
faut pas exagérer leur foi au brise
qu'ils ont pour le brésil est un pays
occidental nous l'oublions souvent mais
ici c'est l'occident et donc nous avons
les mêmes maladies entre guillemets que
l'occident que la france ou l'europe
il ya une très forte via la mort du code
du bateau licite mais l'église
s'effondrent les églises catholiques se
vide et une partie seulement une partie
est récupéré par les évangélistes qui
sont les amis de bossonnens sa femme et
évangéliste lui les catholiques mais
très proche de mon droit de manger donc
ce qui se passe au fait donc la fois au
brésil
elle n'est pas aussi aider pensent-ils
forte que ça ce que ce que par contre
bolton araud
résumé incarne c'est à dire c'est qu'il
t'a le ctc branché sur le bon sens
populaire il est il a compris le qu'il
ya aujourd'hui deux types de deux fois
qu'il ya eu une cassure dans la société
entre les gens qui sont qui peuvent
vivre qui peuvent traverser le coup vide
à la maison en remote office et ce
qu'ils peuvent
qu'ils ne peuvent pas s'empêcher de de
sortir de chez eux donc je pense pas
qu'il faille exagéré l'aspect de la la
fois religieux c'est plus une île à une
connexion avec des classes populaires
qui sont souvent vilipendé dans les
médias qui sont célébrés en france qu'on
appelle lé beau félin lui il le repas et
ils sont nombreux
il y avait donc c'est ce qui à mon avis
va lui l'uefa lui amener des troupes
électoral plus en plus nombreux alors
justement cette popularité chez ces
classes là est-ce que d'un point de vue
économique on peut penser que j'ai un
bol sonar ou taxe les riches pour
relancer l'économie
on verra ce que va faire son mini d'être
de l'économie par le guen ce qui est
d'abord un spécialiste de lait produit
parce que pour son art est un militaire
et qu'ils étaient formés en profitèrent
prof d'éducation physique dans l'armée
un boxer c'est pas un billet d'économies
alors que monsieur par le hockey c'est
très fort ça libérale et pro de chicago
lui il veut libéraliser l'économie
il lui l'a commise en 12 % de déficit du
du pid cette année alexis budgétaire par
port hopping l'idée c'est de créer des
nouveaux impôts
de toute façon les riches au brésil sont
pas très taxée et la taxation président
est très injuste sur ton pour le capital
le brésil un pays pour les dividendes
sont pas sont pas très taxée donc il ya
une réforme qu'on appelle tripoter abl
fiscale qui qui star game qui vivotent
dans parlement on sait pas au fait la
réponse à votre question c'est que
derrière en coulisse aujourd'hui il ya
ya ya ya des négociations parce qu'on a
le comité a donné un impôt de pour sa
console en termes de popularité
et même dans l'opposition se dit des
négociations pour un second mandat il
peut envisager un second mandat j'ai un
golden arrow pour conclure oui
clairement enfin on sait pas dans deux
ans ce pas ce qui va se passer
moi je pense qu'il est bien parti parce
que 40 % de popularité de noailles à 30
% de gens qui votent beau sonar ou par
conviction parce que ce sont des
religieux parce que ce sont des gens qui
détestent la gauche donc 30% de socle
électoral fixé énorme
à deux ans des élections mais les
niveaux auxquels je fais référence et
avec l'opposition
avec les gens du centre-gauche qu'ils
aient la vie rabot sur la rocky qui
faisait d'eux qu'ils entrent apparaît au
niveau du parlement ne votant pas les
les lois parce que ça paie
parlementariste ici leur président ils
sont en train de négocier pour à la
limite qui leur donne des postes
ministériels et des députés secrétariat
et qu' il le laisse faire ces réformes
économiques dont celle de fiscalité donc
peut-être qu'on est en train de voir un
bol sonar au nouveau qui va paraître un
peu plus consensuel parce qu'il va
devoir passer des alliances c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle je trouve pour le
brésil de voir que le pays redevienne
bien merci beaucoup
driss ghali pour vos précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste en
relations internationales
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur l'interview télévisée d'emmanuel
macron prévue demain est très attendue
par les français avec de probables
nouvelles restrictions rue puis nous
parlerons de l'europe italie allemagne
et royaume-uni serre la vis face à la
deuxième vague de l'épidémie a tout de
suite sur rt france
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dira écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qui bat là-bas c'est fini pour
moi est ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du malheur mais
quel est le rapport avec la réducation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
on est sur des bourses qui se porte bien
alors qu'on sait très bien que
l'économie en général est très très très
très loin derrière les actions ne sont
plus le reflet d'une activité humaine
ce sont de purs objets mathématiques
parce que cette crise est liée au corps
et dix neuf elle a accentué ce décalage
entre l'économie réelle et les marchés
boursiers sont déconnectés depuis déjà
un bon moment c'est depuis que les
banques centrales ont une politique
d'impression monétaire et ses fameux
quantitative easing
les gérants sont simplement là comme des
gens des terminaux pour affecter le cash
dont il dispose à bas le risque que ça
c'est que à un moment on se fait comme
dans les dessins animés ou se réveille
et on s'aperçoit qu'on est au dessus du
lit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme s'est pas toute
fiabilité du projet ne serait ce qu'au
business et on oscille entre 92 et 98
points 5 % ça fonctionne bien ça permet
un d'être rapide d'être non invasif et
puis d'avoir le résultat de façon
instantanée avec un coût qui est quand
même bien moindre plus que sont les
coûts actuels d'épaisseur on va pas
sauver l'humanité souffrent pour
révolutionner les choses avec le travail
qu'on fait aux peut-être faire en sorte
qu'on fasse appel à un savoir faire qui
est un savoir-faire médical aussi dans
un domaine un peu différente et celui de
l'animal mais après tout l'homme c'est
un animal populo
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une à l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
refermait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais plaint d'une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend quelle
valeur on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
n'aura un débat éthique
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs a
certes chohada et tout le monde discute
et finalement tu mon discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois voyez des images assez
touchants de l'armée qui était presque
impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause des hommes politiques et
sont en train de manipuler l'armée on
sait très bien pourquoi ils nous tirent
dessus sais pas s'ils savent que c'est
leur fin ils se préparent le seul
langage qu'ils connaissaient la violence
ne va pas être violent mais on va rester
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 13 octobre 2020 en france veillée
d'armes plutôt conseil de défense avant
l'interview d'emmanuel maquereau à la
télévision demain soir face à la
dégradation de la situation sanitaire
de nouvelles mesures sont à attendre
pour réduire la circulation du virus
couvre-feu confinement local télétravail
et les hypothèses ne manquent pas alors
que pour la première fois depuis le
printemps
le nombre de malades en réanimation a
dépassé la barre des 1500 suscitant les
pires craintes du monde hospitalier
[Musique]
le vieux continent confronté à la
deuxième vague resserre la vis en italie
le décret signé par le premier ministre
josé paix compte est interdit notamment
les fêtes et célébrations à l'extérieur
comme dans les lieux fermés
outre-rhin berlin instaure un couvre-feu
au royaume uni c'est un système à trois
niveaux d' alerte moyen risqué et très
risqué qui a été annoncé par boris
johnson
avec un seul but endiguer l'épidémie et
éviter un confinement général l'europe
va pouvoir surtaxer les importations
américaines à hauteur de 4 milliards de
dollars à l'annoncé a été faite ce mardi
par l'organisation mondiale du commerce
qui se pose comme arbitre dans une
guerre commerciale
la vieille de quinze ans elle a raison
des versements illégitimes accordées par
les états unis à l'avionneur américain
boeing
washington avait déjà été autorisée à
taxer des produits en provenance du
vieux continent pour un montant de 7
milliards et demi de dollars après des
aides européennes à airbus
bruxelles appelle de son côté à un
accord négocié avec les états unis
washington veut intensifier les
négociations pour une juste concurrence
[Musique]
la france doit rester neutre face au
conflit dans le haut-karabagh ce sont
les mots de jean yves le drian
alors que certains élus français appelle
à prendre parti pour l'arménie
sur place les combats continuent entre
forces indépendantistes arménienne et
l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
moscou et washington et berlin appellent
les deux corps à respecter le cessez le
feu conclu dans le cadre du groupe dit
de minsk
[Musique]
et on commence avec la situation
sanitaire en france avec un point sur
les derniers chiffres santé publique
france annonce 12 1993 nouvelles
contaminations aux copies de 19 ans 24
heures en hausse par rapport à mardi
dernier 87 personnes sont décédées à
l'hôpital
le taux de positivité s'établit
désormais à 12% et les instituteurs sont
ils les grands oubliés face au co vite
19 c'est en tout cas ce qui ressort
d'une enquête publiée par smip fsu
principal syndicat d'enseignants du
primaire 80% des enseignants interrogés
se sentent mal ou très mal protégés en
classe face au virus
plus de quatre enseignants sur cinq donc
le syndicat pointe la difficulté
d'assurer la distanciation physique
entre les élèves et les gestes barrières
que les enseignants ne sont plus en
capacité de faire respecter
il demande un protocole sanitaire
renforcée enseignants professeurs en
grande difficulté donc face à la crise
sanitaire tout comme les soignants en
première ligne face à la résurgence de
l'épidémie alors quelle réponse doit
apporter le gouvernement pour ces
professionnels dont le moral est en
berne
on en parle tout de suite avec nos
invités place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec bruno
megaman chef du service de réanimation
de l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
bonsoir à vos côtés
line numa-droz cage professeur des
universités spécialiste de l'éducation
et psychologue au bon soir alors l'hymne
uma blocage pas de changement dans les
écoles prévu la situation est sous
contrôle assure ce soir jean-michel
bloquèrent on a entendu l'inquiétude des
enseignants également face à cette crise
sanitaire quel est votre regard sur
l'état d'esprit des enseignants
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que le
gouvernement pourrait leur proposer
selon vous alors le regard quand orthez
correspond tout à fait à ce que votre
enquête a laissé paraître c'est à dire
une certaine anxiété à la fois pour le
métier qu'ils ont à faire est ce qu'ils
peuvent continuer à enseigner dans ces
conditions et pour leurs élèves qui à la
fois ne peuvent pas maintenir la
distanciation physique mais aussi ne
peuvent pas forcément à prendre dans de
bonnes conditions
et puis également pour eux mêmes et pour
les conditions dans lesquelles il exerce
alors est ce que le gouvernement peut
intervenir il ya sans doute des choses à
faire très certainement parce que les
conditions dans les écoles sont ne sont
pas satisfaisantes du tout en état
actuel et la difficulté et l'anxiété
pour les enseignants s'est malgré tout
dit d'essayer de maintenir le sens de
leur métier c'est-à-dire enseigner et
comment le faire dans ces conditions la
burqa la fermeture des écoles qui ne
semble pas à l'ordre du jour
c'est une bonne chose pour les élèves
selon vous oui pour les élèves je pense
que c'est une très bonne chose parce que
j'ai eu l'occasion dans le cadre d'une
recherche qui a été qui est soutenu par
la sf d'interroger des élèves pendant la
période du confinement il est apparu
qu'ils arrivaient à s'en sortir et qu'il
ne faisait preuve de beaucoup
d'inventivité de créativité donc qu'ils
arrivent à apprendre
malgré la distanciation effective et
dans laquelle il se trouvait au moment
du confinement
mais le besoin de l'aide que pouvait
leur apporter leurs enseignants quel que
soit le niveau de classe en fait il
ressorti
comme un élément incontournable pour eux
et puis arrivé également on pourrait
dire en 2d le fait de pouvoir rencontrer
leurs amis d'être avec les autres et
donc de se développer dans les échanges
qu'il pouvait avoir avec bruno meier
germann fin septembre vous faisait
partie d'un groupe de médecins vous
demander des mesures radicales pour
faire face au regain de l'épidémie
coronavirus couvre-feu leur confinement
locale ce sont des mesures aujourd'hui
qui sont sur toutes les lèvres de bonne
mesure selon vous où elles sont
nécessaires
alors on va dire des fins et en nous
demandions à la population d'être plus
stricts et plus responsable dans le
comportement quotidien
c'est à dire d'appliquer mieux les
mesures barrières le port du masque non
seulement dans l'espace public mais
également dans l'espace privatif c'est à
dire lorsqu'il y à des rassemblements
amicaux où des rassemblements familiaux
élargi car c'est ce cercle privé
constitue est constitué le lieu
principal des contaminations à l'époque
évidemment nous ne demandions nullement
de mesures plus draconiennes
on pensait que la simple
responsabilisation pourrait permettre de
stabiliser voire d'infléchir les courbes
de contamination force est de constater
que depuis maintenant deux mois
les contaminations augmente à une
vitesse certes lente mais néanmoins
constante avec désormais une arrivée
importante de patients vers les services
d'urgence et de réanimation
les jeunes qui s'étaient contaminés au
départ ont désormais transmis le virus
vers des personnes plus âgées qui
malheureusement présente désormais des
formes plus graves
venant à l'hôpital aujourd'hui en ile de
france environ 45 % des lits de
réanimation sont occupés par des
patients présentant des formes graves de
co vite donc très logiquement évidemment
pour pouvoir
casser la coupe de contamination il est
attendu que le gouvernement prenne des
mesures désormais un peu plus strictes
évidemment pour éviter que le système de
santé s'effondre dans deux ou trois mois
et qu'il faille recourir au confinement
généralisée comme un couvre feu par
exemple vous êtes pour alors je peux pas
me prononcer évidemment si je suis pour
ou contre c'est pas c'est pas dans ces
termes je ne dispose pas bien sûr ni des
chiffres ni des données permettant de
prendre une décision
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'effectivement le principe du couvre
feu c'est de restreindre la nuit la
circulation et l'interaction sociale
entre les individus
car de fait évidemment on peut pas
légiférer et interdire les réunions dans
le cercle privé
donc ce sont des mesures qui ont
démontré leur efficacité dans d'autres
pays
elles sont d'ailleurs appliqué
actuellement en allemagne y compris un
niveau de circulation du virus plus
faibles donc je dirai ce sont des
mesures à monet de bon sens je pense
elles ne viennent pas trop tard elles
permettront malgré tout de freiner dans
une certaine mesure la progression de
l'épidémie et on l'espère évidemment
permettent de sauver le système de santé
pour qu'ils puissent maintenir son offre
de soins la totalité de la population
alors avec des soignants qui sont de
plus en plus nombreux on le disait ces
derniers jours à vouloir quitter
l'hôpital parce que c'est trop dur parce
qu'il n'ya pas assez de moyens on disait
tout à l'heure effectivement que les
enseignants également avait eu une
baisse de moral est ce qu'on peut
craindre une fuite des enseignants dans
les semaines dans les mois à venir selon
vous l'inhumer blocage par rapport à
cette situation sanitaire que nous
sommes en train de vivre
je ne sais pas exactement ce que vous
entendez par fuite
je pense qu'il est bébé par des des
enseignants qui partirait finalement
face à une situation à un métier qui est
devenu trop joue trop dur trop
contraignant aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on en
est là aujourd'hui dans l'éducation
nationale
alors effectivement je n'ai les
décisions sont difficiles je pense que
pour certains on peut se retrouver dans
dix cas de ré interrogations du sens
qu'ils donnent à leurs métiers je ne
crois pas que dans la majorité des
enseignants veulent forcément fuir ce
métier parce que ils ont plutôt au
contraire conscience de la place qu'ils
ont dans ce qui se passe en ce moment et
de leur rôle
donc je pense que c'est plutôt un
comportement de responsabilité qui se
dégage des enseignants et moi dans les
contacts que j'ai pu avoir les
recherches que nous avons menées sur
cette question il y avait au contraire
une très grande préoccupation relative
au sens à donner à leur métier dans la
majorité des cas compte tenu de ces
nouvelles conditions
c'est à dire que des enseignants se
posaient vraiment les questions de ce
qu'on appelle la dit d'activation de
leur enseignement c'est à dire comment
continuer à enseigner quand on est à
distance alors qu'on a tout préparé pour
une activité qui doit se dérouler en
présentiel dont classe ce sont des
questions qui se posent
on leur demande de penser des courants
terme d'hybridation ils le font
remarquer qu'il leur manque du matériel
il ya un problème d'équipement de deux
d'accès à certaines on va dire certaines
conditions ne serait ce que pour avoir
la distance d'avoir internet de pouvoir
être abonnés d'avoir un flux suffisant
pour pouvoir répondre à ces conditions
là donc dans une telle position je ne
crois pas que les gens est envie de
quitter le métier mais ils demandent
d'autres conditions de travail ça c'est
c'est plutôt la revendication de la
majorité des enseignants
il y a également le souci des élèves et
tout à l'heure il était question
peut-être d'envisager der confinement
même localiser compte tenu des
conditions qui peuvent se trouver à
l'intérieur dans le privé dans les
familles ce qui est ressorti de
l'enquète si que pour certains enfants
qui vivaient dans des appartements ou
dans des maisons
le fait d'être confiné avait été une
solution intéressante parce qu'ils
pouvaient avoir d'autres liens avec
leurs familles des liens qu'ils
n'avaient plus mais dans d'autres cas
c'était plutôt des conditions
extrêmement difficiles et on a craint
pour certains enfants qui se
retrouvaient dans des appartements
réduit avec des familles et au niveau
psychologique
il ya probablement des effets de cette
situation
bruno meyer banes que la problématique
des effectifs à venir est ce que vous
vous le craignez c'est une vraie
question aujourd'hui un manque de
personnel soignant pour faire face à
cette seconde vague
oui tout à fait on va dire au cours du
premier pic épidémique
l'épidémie a atteint deux régions
principalement le grand est et la région
ile de france
et lorsque nous avons dû ouvrir en
catastrophe un nombre important de lits
de réanimation
lorsqu on est sortis des murs c'est à
dire lorsqu'on a mis des lits dans des
secteurs qui n'étaient pas initialement
dédiée à l'animation nous avons reçu des
renforts venant d'autres régions et
venant de cliniques privées
malheureusement cette fois-ci l'épidémie
touche la totalité du territoire
national et donc il est très peu
probable que l'on puisse bénéficier
d'une dune d'une telle aide venant de
l'extérieur
il faut donc compter uniquement sur ses
ressources internes et malheureusement
comme vous le dites
le personnel soignant et en nombre
limité il ya un manque chronique
notamment de personnels spécialisés en
réanimation et donc effectivement ça
peut être le point de difficulté pour
pouvoir augmenter le capacitaire de lit
en réanimation
alors il faut compter en plus sur la
fatigue est peut-être la démotivation de
certains personnels malgré tout nous
ferons tout en notre possible avec les
moyens disponibles pour soigner la
totalité des patients qui les locaux
vides ou non merci beaucoup bruno
megaman rappelle que vous êtes chef du
service de réanimation de l'hôpital
lariboisière merci à vous line numa
bocage professeur des universités
spécialiste
de l'éducation et psychologues l'union
européenne unifie ces critères pour les
restrictions de voyage le ministre des
affaires européenne réunis au luxembourg
ont adopté aujourd'hui un texte dans ce
sens
il prévoit notamment une cartographie
commune pour définir les zones à risque
au sein de l'union européenne
les explications de rania berrada est ce
enfin le retour de schengen c'est à dire
la possibilité pour les voyageurs
européens de se déplacer librement dans
cet espace où les contrôles aux
frontières sont en temps normal abolie
et bien presque les critères communs
adopté par les ministres des affaires
européennes ce mardi veulent en tout cas
tendre vers ce monde d'avant premières
mesures une cartographie commune pour
définir les zones à risque au sein de
lieux
le texte prévoit que le centre européen
de prévention et de contrôle des
maladies publie chaque semaine une carte
de la situation de l'ensemble des pays
de l'union au niveau régional une carte
avec des codes couleur vert orange rouge
ou grise lorsque les données sont
insuffisantes pour classifier la zone en
question sont prises en compte le nombre
de nouveaux cas notifiés pour 100000
habitants sur les 14 derniers jours et
le taux de positivité déteste les
voyageurs venant d'une zone orange rouge
ou de crises peuvent se voir imposer à
l'arrivée une quarantaine et où un
dépistage ceux qui viennent d'une zone
verte ne sont soumis à aucune mesure il
ya un succès majeur qui sera acté
aujourd'hui c'est celui d'une
coordination des critères sanitaires
dans la lutte contre la copie de 19 pour
que nous ayons les mêmes mesures partout
en europe les mêmes critères de décision
pour limiter les restrictions aux
déplacements
réservez les déplacements
transfrontaliers ils sont absolument
essentielles et donner de la visibilité
à nos citoyens à nos entreprises dans
cette période qui est déjà difficile
ce texte qui est une recommandation donc
sans contrainte ne fait pas l'unanimité
plusieurs pays se sont d'ailleurs
abstenus dont le luxembourg
son ministre des affaires étrangères
estime que le texte doit être je cite
complètes et approfondies en ajoutant
d'autres critères autres mesures
retenues celle de la reconnaissance
mutuelle des tests et des exemptions de
quarantaine pour les voyageurs exerçant
des fonctions jugé essentiel un
formulaire européen unique à remplir par
les voyageurs devraient également voir
le jour
reste à savoir si les états se plieront
à ces mesures sur la durée
eux qui n'ont pas pu se cordonner lors
des fermetures des frontières au
printemps et de leur réouverture durant
l'été
si le vieux continent adoptent des
restrictions commune plusieurs pays
prennent chacun à leur tour des mesures
supplémentaires face au regain de
l'épidémie en italie
le décret signé par le premier ministre
que vous êtes est compté pour 30 jours
interdit notamment aux bars et
restaurants de servir des clients non à
6 après 21h il interdit les fêtes et
célébrations à l'extérieur comme dans
les lieux fermés et limite à six le
nombre d'invités à domicile outre-rhin
les allemands veulent à tout prix garder
le contrôle le cap des 4000 4010 9
détecté en 24 heures a été à nouveau
dépassé pour la troisième fois en une
semaine un arsenal de règles sanitaires
et déployer avec des règles différentes
dans les 16 länder
et puis du côté du royaume uni l'un des
pays les plus touchés au monde par le
comique 19 confronté à une sérieuse
deuxième vague
elle était attendue boris johnson a
annoncé hier de nouvelles mesures plus
fermes
accueillie avec hostilité au combat
à durham la pression n'est pas réservé
qu'aux pop qui jalonnent la ville elles
montrent également dans les hôpitaux de
la région
avec plus de dix mille nouveaux cas de
kobe de 19 par jour
l'angleterre est le symbole de la
deuxième vague qui frappe le royaume uni
une situation particulièrement
inquiétante dans la région nord qui a
obligé le premier ministre britannique à
réagir
le niveau d' alerte très élevé
s'appliquera là où les taux de
transmission augmente le plus rapidement
et là où le système de santé publique
pourraient bientôt être soumis à une
pression insupportable sans autre
restriction dans ces domaines le
gouvernement établira une base de
référence pour interdire les contacts de
sociaux en intérieur et dans les jardins
privés et je suis désolé de dire la
fermeture des peuples et des bars une
base devant les députés
boris johnson a présenté le nouveau
système d' alerte à trois niveaux qui
aura pour objectif de mettre fin au
patchwork actuel de restrictions qui
touchent l'angleterre le pays de galles
l'écossé et l'irlande du nord est
incompétent pour appliquer leur propre
dispositif trois échelons moyen élevé et
très élevé qui détermineront le niveau
de privation des zones affectées par le
cos vite 19 un mécanisme ayant pour but
d'éviter tout nouveau re confinement
généralisée causse de le veulent bien
sûr il ya ceux qui disent que dans cette
logique nous devrions retourner dans un
confinement général national d'une durée
indéterminée
fermer les écoles et les entreprises
dire aux gens de rester à la maison
comme nous l'avons fait en mars fermant
une fois de plus nos vies et notre
société je ne pense pas que ce serait la
bonne voie une volonté de sauver des
vies donc mais également de soutenir
l'économie des mesures de chômage
partiel ont été prises notamment pour
accompagner les pubs et restaurants
affectée par les mesures de confinement
localiser insuffisant pour ce gérant
d'une pizzeria et aujourd'hui j'ai gagné
300 livres je dépense 1000 livres par
semaine pour l'électricité pour le four
à pizza trois employés à 8 9 livres de
l'heure ce qu'il propose ça ne couvre
rien absolument rien
donc on va l'absolu drainantes et si les
élus de la région de liverpool ont
accepté de fermer bar salle de gym et
autres casinos les négociations avec
d'autres élus du nord du pays s'annonce
compliquée il ya pourtant urgence
le royaume-uni est le pays le plus
touché par le coronavirus en europe avec
près de 40 de 1800 morts et 6 118 mille
cas positifs et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis londres avec
martin mc cauley il est analyste
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur
[Musique]
martin mc cauley merci est d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france
alors ces mesures dites présenté par
boris johnson comment elles ont été
reçues par la population outre-manche
plutôt avec hostilité à une telle
aujourd'hui envoyé une photographie de
musique jour je suis dit tout ce qu'il
ya à dire sur le sur le visage il est
épuisé après sept mois de prison
ce visage exprime la nécessité qu'on
m'explique comment résoudre ce problème
qui semble tout à fait insolubles aux
nues il a annoncé de nouvelles
restrictions
le gouvernement a publié une application
car je vais télécharger que je suis à
londres l'oscar une zone où le niveau
d'alerté est moyen
c'est le niveau le plus bas c'est à dire
que les restaurants et les pubs doivent
fermer à 22h les que mutu ne peut pas se
rassembler à plus de six personnes dans
you enjoy
cela continuera jusqu'à ce que la
situation pire
la difficulté pour personne qu'il n'est
pas un scientifique il n'apas étudié les
mathématiques la physique la chimie
ligne connaît pas ces sciences dures qui
enseigne la probabilité les statistiques
qui est vécu que toute connaissance est
temporaire et il se fonde sur des avis
reçus de scientifiques par exemple en
mars en avril à qui se sont avérés ne
pas d'être correctement
il est donc dans une situation très
difficile car les scientifiques ne sont
pas d'accord sur ce qu'il faut faire et
il doit décider à qui il faut pas faire
confiance aux hommes wang a vu que
certains scientifiques veulent un
confinement total
castanet pas à demander un confinement
dur pour deux à trois semaines
mais le premier ministre est contre
cette idée car cela paralyserait
l'économie et c'est là bas le grand
problème propre origine sony doit
trouver un homme libre h12 entre les
conseils des scientifiques et hommes qui
demandent à dublin confinement et à des
consignes très draconiennes
ceux qui gèrent les communes de
travailleurs par exemple qui va
continuer à travailler car par exemple
le secteur de la restauration devrait
fermer s'il y avait finement durs tels
que les scientifiques le conseil de vol
de vélos c'est une situation très
complexe pour le premier et cette fois
ci il essaye de deviner que les
restrictions à bonnières a fact auront
l'effet désiré use deux le nombre des
contaminations
hier était de 14 ans et c'était le plus
attendu depuis quelques temps et elle a
cru que cela continue à augmenter et si
c'est le cas alors la situation pourrait
devenir critique j'ai revu et londres
pas mieux loti est une région où
l'alerté de niveau moyen
la situation est encore acceptable la
ville de liverpool par exemple est
confiné avec un niveau d alerte c'est
très élevé et d'autres régions du
nord-ouest de l'angleterre également de
niveau d'alerté élevé une boussole et la
population est plus que ces troubles et
car les scientifiques scientifiques
disent quelque chose et d'autres le
contraire chaque fois que je sors je
porte un masque parker m'a dit de le
faire jouer beaucoup le font pas car
certains scientifiques disent qu'on n'a
pas besoin de masques cela ne fait pas
no kuni ferrand la situation est source
de confusion
premier ministre en tout cas est très
compliqué et il doit essayer de trouver
un cap ces deux extrêmes entre les
scientifiques et ceux qui veulent une
économie normale
en quelques mots ou est-ce que le ton de
boris johnson a changé est ce que vous
le sentez moins optimiste aujourd'hui il
ya spéculent que la photographie c'est
la première fois toujours été optimiste
passé au bout seul mais moi je prends
une cool news c'est un engin qui
pourrait apporter de quoi vous pouvez
leur dire ce que la population au fond
il faut qu'il soit heureux de tous était
un jour un dirigeant peut être populaire
et ne veut pas il dira des choses
négatives à la population il est donc
très attentifs à ce qu'il dit car il
veut propager un message positif et
beaucoup de personnes ne le crois pas
car ils voient ce qui se passe dans le
pays il ya certaines personnes dans le
monde considère qu'il veut devenir un
dictateur qui le vit comme jo en rayer
la démocratie car par exemple il refuse
le débat au parlement qui le boulot il
n'aime pas cela pour eux c'est un risque
pour la dernière info pour la liberté
jours donc il souhaiterait prendre leurs
propres décisions de personnes en
angleterre
je voudrais choisir eux mêmes mais la
majorité des gens voudraient que le
gouvernement soit plus sévère qu'il le
mette en place des mesures plus fortes
pour mettre un terme à cette pénalité
donc des mesures fortes sont de
meilleurs de tueries souhaite le visage
de brice jeanselme et je montre bien
qu'il est épuisé et d'illoula je
trouvais très difficile de trouver des
solutions
en tout cas ils implorent le public de
suivre ses directives car cela aidera le
plus la population
un grand merci martin mc cauley d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes analyste politique
restez avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de la
guerre commerciale entre l'europe et les
états unis
le mcr autorisé bruxelles à imposer des
surtaxes sur 4 milliards de dollars de
produits importés des états unis et puis
nous reviendrons sur la situation au
karabagh le chef de la diplomatie
américaine mike pompéo appel arménie et
azerbaïdjan a appliqué un cessez le feu
a tout de suite sur rt france
[Musique]
on est sur des bourses qui se porte bien
alors qu'on sait très bien que
l'économie en général est très très très
très loin derrière les actions ne sont
plus le reflet d'une activité humaine
ce sont de purs objets mathématiques
parce que cette crise est liée au corps
et dix neuf elle a accentué ce décalage
entre l'économie réelle et les marchés
boursiers sont déconnectés depuis déjà
un bon moment c'est depuis que les
banques centrales ont une politique
d'impression monétaire et ses fameux
quantitative easing
les gérants sont simplement là comme des
gens des terminaux pour affecter le cash
dont il dispose à bas le risque que ça
c'est qu'à un moment on se fait comme
dans les dessins animés ou se réveille
et s'aperçoit qu'on est au dessus du lit
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
était assez violente d'ailleurs entre
les russes et les américains alors que
j'étais destinée à voler avec les russes
mais une opportunité s'est ouverte de
faire partie du deuxième groupe
d'astronautes européens qui m'a envoyé
aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa va entraîner qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout ça on le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de nos terres
[Musique]
je
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 21h30
heure française à l'om c'est s'apprête à
autoriser l'union européenne à prendre
des mesures de rétorsion contre
washington pour ses aides à boeing un
rebondissement de plus dans un
feuilleton commercial vieux de 16 ans le
point avec samir sami et leïla sarraf
des attaques et contre attaques qui ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui
en octobre 2004 l'administration bush
déposé plainte contre l'union européenne
considérant que les aides du vieux
continent airbus entravaient les règles
de la concurrence
l'union européenne veut rendre coup pour
coup et accuse à son tour les états unis
d'utiliser des fonds publics pour
subventionner l'avionneur américain
boeing
l'om c'est duncan cause aux deux parties
[Musique]
l'organisation de régulation
internationale rend un verdict ferme
exhortant washington et bruxelles à se
mettre en conformité avec les règles de
l'organisation internationale
européens et américains font appel de la
décision
il y a tout juste un an le 2 octobre
l'om c'est prononcer la plus lourde
sanction de son histoire contre l'union
européenne elle autorisait les états
unis à imposer des droits de douane de
prêt de 7,5 milliards de dollars sur des
importations en provenance du vieux
continent des sanctions douanières
aussitôt appliqué sur plusieurs produits
comme le vin français et espagnol
l'huile d'olive espagnole ou encore le
whisky écossais ce mardi la balle
revient dans le camp de l'union
européenne l'om c'est lui permet
d'imposer de nouveaux tarifs douaniers
sur environ quatre milliards de dollars
de produits américains
sauf règlement du conflit à l'amiable
les sanctions commerciales que risquent
de subir l'avionneur américain pourrait
bien clouer définitivement boeing au sol
et pour en parler nous sommes avec henri
sterdyniak économiste à l'ofce
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques
henri sterdyniak merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france l'om ca a donc
autorisé ce mardi des sanctions
européennes contre les états unis
qu'est ce qui a motivé cette décision
qu'elle est le noeud du problème
le noeud du problème c'est que les deux
pays subventionne d'ailleurs les
avionneurs donc l'europe subventionne
airbus les états unis subventionne bruit
et que chaque ars titeux actionneurs
fait pression auprès du gouvernement
pour que ceux couverts portes place à
l'om c'est contre le partenaire et donc
on a une sorte de jeu à celle du sang et
donc les états unis ont gagné
il y a 6 mois et ce coup-ci c'est à
l'europe de gagner c'est un jeu bizarre
effectivement vous lisiez les états unis
avaient déjà été autorisées à taxer les
produits en provenance du vieux
continent pour un montent à montans
pardon de 7 milliards et demi de dollars
pour la même raison cette fois avec une
aide un dieu des pays européens à airbus
pourquoi le montant des taxes des
américains est supérieur à celui des
européens qui est de 4 milliards inscrit
le principe de l'om sait c'est que les
autorisations sont dépendantes des z
effectivement accordé et de l' avantage
que ça fournit à airbus c'est donc le le
web loïc est en queue leu leu omc a
estimé que les avantages dont vous avez
avait bénéficié beaux ils sont un peu
inférieures à celles dont airbus avait
bénéficié et c'est ce qui explique cette
différence de montants alors l'union
européenne appelle à la négociation
est ce que cela veut dire
si les états unis retirent leurs droits
de douane les européens ne taxerons pas
les importations oui bien sûr c'est
effectivement la solution la plus sage
harry les deux pays doivent reconnaître
que en fait
l'aviation a besoin d'être aidé surtout
dans la période actuelle est donc il
faudrait que les deux pays renonce à
cette taxation
surtout que ces surtaxes fera des
produits qui a priori n'ont rien à voir
avec l'aviation et que les surtaxes sa
nuit aussi aux consommateurs de chacun
des pays et le l'amérique taxe les
fromages europe et à ce qui nuit d'une
certaine façon au consommateur américain
et l'europe va taxer lekic ap où les les
patates douces importé des états unis ce
qui va nuire aux consommateurs européens
est ce que les états unis seraient
d'accord pour cet accord demandée par
bruxelles
est-ce qu'il l'entende de cette oreille
disons tout va tout va ce négocier en
principe avec une personne raisonnable
on voit qu'un accord serait aussi le
peut-être qu'il va falloir attendre le
départ de donald trump a le problème de
donald trump c'est qu'il a une grande
liste de griefs contre l'europe
il ya un seul mort airbus il ya aussi le
fait que l'allemagne apporte trop de
véhicules automobiles au aux états unis
il ya le fait que cette les pays
européens veulent taxer les caf a donc
d'un hâle trump est engagée dans une
guerre commerciale en grande partie
contre la chine mais aussi contre
l'union européenne et donc la
négociation va être difficile tant qu
effectivement donald homme sera au
pouvoir à washington ont dit attendre de
l'union européenne une réponse à une
récente proposition de quel type de
proposition peut-il s'agir les
propositions de tram c
de d'accepter une limitation volontaire
des importations de exportations de
l'union européenne vers le les états
unis et c'est aussi de renoncer à taxer
les gaffes annoncé une négociation
globale trompe
la tactique de krups et de faire
pression sur chacun de ses partenaire
commercial on met en quelque sorte que
le pistolet sous la tempe en menaçant à
chaque fois de faire des tensions des
des sanctions le problème de l'europe
cee chacun des pays peut avoir des
intérêts différents
lalanne est très préoccupé par le fait
que les états unis veulent limiter les
importations allemandes les exportations
allemandes vers les états unis
alors que ça concerne moins les autres
pays européens alors le ministre
français de l'économie l'a affirmé si
les états unis ne retirent pas leurs
propres taxes nous devons rééquilibrer
le rapport
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à une
guerre commerciale qui dure on le
rappelle elle a commencé il ya 16 ans le
jusqu'à présent on a monté on a lu
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de trump on
a une montée des tensions entre rome
bâle augmenter massivement les taxes sur
les impôts les exportations chinoises
il veut pratique il a pratiqué des
politiques de menaces excluant vol
violentes contre le canada contre le
mexique et contre le roc il
il veut faire pareil sachant qu'il est
il s'estime en position de force puisque
les etats-unis importent beaucoup plus
de l'europe que l'europe importe des
deux états unis et donc il est très
différent très difficile d'aboutir à un
cessez le feu à une baisse
de l'ensemble des détaxes parce que
trump considère que le couple coupable
c'est l'europe puisque l'europe lui
exporte trop de marchandises tandis que
l'europe considère que le coupable c'est
les états unis qui ne respectent pas les
règles du jeu dance
merci beaucoup henri sterdyniak pour
votre éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
économiste à la fcl l'observatoire
français des conjonctures économiques
dans le haut-karabagh à présent la
france doit rester neutre ce sont les
mots de jean yves le drian aujourd'hui
le chef de la diplomatie française
rejette ainsi la peine de certains élus
à prendre parti pour l'arménie
sur place les combats se poursuivent des
combats en violation d'une trêve
humanitaire négocié sous médiation russe
moscou washington et paris qui appelle
donc les deux camps à respecter le
cessez le feu dans le cadre du groupe
dit de minsk bakou et erevan s'accusent
mutuellement d'être responsables des
hostilités pour la porte parole du
ministère azéri des affaires étrangères
le cessez le feu ne constitue pas une
résolution du conflit écouter le fait
que l'arménie viole de manière flagrante
le cessez le feu
la trêve humanitaire témoigne de la
fragilité de cette trêve nous avons
souligné des années durant qu'un cessez
le feu ou non peut le qualifier de trêve
ne constituait pas une solution au
conflit
le cessez-le-feu ne peut être qu'un
moyen pour faire avancer le processus
préliminaire de la résolution pacifique
du conflit
manifestement l'arménie poursuit son
agression contre l'azerbaïdjan leur
objectif étant évidemment de reprendre
le contrôle des territoires azéris
occupés
concernant la durée potentielle de la
trêve c'est à l'autre camp qu'il faut
poser la question puisque l'arménie
continue de faire la sourde oreille et
de bombarder les régions azéri et
l'arménie et le pointe du doigt la
responsabilité de l'azerbaïdjan dans le
conflit
nos équipes de r t internationales ont
interviewé
le président arménien tout de suite un
extrait est il des violations de la part
de l'arménie et s'il y en a pour quoi il
ya certainement eu des infractions
d'après ce que je comprends si une
partie comme une transgression l'autre
partie réplique
et puis tout cela revient au point de
départ qui a agi en premier
premièrement dans le cas des
bombardements à gandja en azerbaïdjan
[Musique]
j'ai des informations précises et
maintenant de mon gouvernement du
ministère de la défense et le ministère
des affaires étrangères on a déjà parlé
ce n'est certainement pas l'arménie qui
la bombarde et voilà pour le premier
point et deuxièmement quand on parle de
violation du cessez-le-feu cela est
arrivé malheureusement immédiatement
après l'annoncé du cessez-le-feu à midi
quand stepanakert la capitale de la
république de l'artsakh du haut karabagh
a été bombardé je parle également de
bombardements visant la population
civile
faire pocher troisièmement on ne doit
pas oublier à cet égard une réalité
qui a initié cette étape de la guerre
c'est à l'évidence le camp azéri pas le
peuple du haut karabagh ou la république
de l'artsakh donc malheureusement il ya
des violations et je pense que toutes
les parties doivent faire beaucoup
d'efforts pour y remédier et bien sûr
c'est très important d'avoir des
mécanismes de vérification déterminons
qui viole un cessez le feu
il ya de nombreux moyens de le faire au
niveau international en utilisant
certaines technologies mais cela doit
entrer en vigueur avant que le cessez le
feu ne soit établi entièrement l'aspect
humanitaire de cette trêve ne sera utile
à aucun des deux camps et un nouveau
rassemblement pour l'arménie s'est tenue
aujourd'hui à paris et cette fois ci
devant l'assemblée nationale le point
avec notre reporter katia technique elle
était sur place se sont regroupés
aujourd'hui à proximité de l'assemblée
nationale
ils sont
dyneema les bombardements qui ont eu
cours dans les eaux khabar qui font de
nombreuses victimes civiles lors des
précédents rassemblements
ils ont avisé l'expansionnisme turc le
soutien israélien aujourd'hui ils en
appellent à la fraise c'est pourquoi de
nombreux drapeaux français voisine avec
lé pavillon arménien on souhaite la
reconnaissance de l'alsace ils sont
indignés ont ils dit à la tribune des
propos de jean yves le drian le ministre
des affaires étrangères qui souhaitent
que la france reste notre reconnaissance
de reconnaissance et une communauté
arménienne
extrêmement ému et je vous propose
d'écouter deux participants à cette
mobilisation
l'azerbaïdjan n'a plus du tout aucune
légitimité a essayé de vouloir récupérer
l'eau coule au karabagh parce que son
attention il l'a déclaré avec les
l'agression militaire du 27 10 27
septembre son attention c'est une
intention génocidaire c'est une
intention de nettoyage ethnique contre
le
contre le peuple arménien qui vit sur
ses terres la guerre poursuit partout
j'ai mon cousin kia d'arménie t puis 17
changeait pas de nouvelles de louis
et là sur le front est ça va très très
mal parce que ça bombarde sans arrêt
pique
personne ne me soutient dans leur a
barré c'est un tout petit pays qui est
qu à ses coutumes ses chansons sa sa
culture il faut le sauver
c'est très important pour nous à noter
dans cette foule de 3000 personnes
environ la présence de très nombreux
élus comme à valérie boyer sénatrice
elle est ou encore françois du petit
députés socialistes et les militants
d'autres qui sont regroupés aujourd'hui
pour demander des actes concrets à la
france et pour en parler nous sommes
avec 10 baldy gasimov docteur en droit
international et spécialiste du caucase
deal baldy gasimov merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france on le
disait jean yves le drian appelle la
france à rester neutre comment vous
comprenez cette posture alors que de
nombreux députés demandent que la france
soutienne l'arménie aujourd'hui vous
savez ces deux mondes sont une
compréhensible dans la mesure où ces
députés qui rappellent qu'ils
fournissent et tapez sont très engagés
aux côtés de la com et arméniens dont
ils ont leurs raisons que j'ignore entre
la position de la france est tout à fait
logique dans premièrement parce que la
france c'est un c'est un grand pays
c'est un cri un pays sérieux
la france a une parole sur la sur la
scène internationale elle ne peut pas se
permettre
faire des déclarations aventuriste qui
peuvent causer de beaucoup de dégâts
beaucoup de dommages d'un côté de
l'autre
donc sachant aussi que la france est un
des coprésidents du groupe de minsk
je crois à mon sens que la france a fait
ce qui convenait de faire et ce qu'on
attendait d'un pays comme la france
alors malgré un cessez le feu annoncé
vendredi dernier entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie
les combats ont repris au karabagh
quelles sont les conditions à réunir
pour une perspective de paix aujourd'hui
si elle est encore possible aujourd'hui
la paix je pense que dans cette guerre
la paix est toujours possible
donc la position d'hazard visualiser la
suivante que l'arménie se retire des
sites régions occupées
là on parle pas de haut karabagh parce
qu'il faut savoir que à part le haut
karabagh qui a sept autres régions
d'azerbaïdjan est ce qu'ils sont occupés
où aucune minorité arménienne ne vivait
avant la guerre donc l'azerbaïjan
demande à ce que l'arménie se retire de
ses sept régions ensuite que les
négociations reprennent pour discuter de
statut de beau-parent rapport
l'azerbaïdjan l'a fait depuis 27 ans
maintenant que les négociations
continuent l'azerbaïdjan l'a toujours
dit et répété qu'elle est prête à
accorder aux arméniens du haut karabagh
le statut de plus important en
respectant leur identité arménienne leur
langue leur culture
en créant un lien qu'elle reste avec
l'arménie sachant que le haut karabagh
il est enclavé en azerbaïdjan
il n'a pas de lien terrestre avec
l'arménie l'azerbaïdjan propose même de
créer inconnu de cours d'eau pour le
karabagh et l'arménie puce communiqué
donc je pense que ces conditions pour
une guerre sanglante de telle ampleur
sont pas mal donc la balle et de côté
arménien c'est l'arménie parce que là on
parle souvent de l'arcep doit karabagh
sachez ça il faut savoir que c'est pas
le haut karabagh ce qui met la guerre
c'est la ruine qui mènent la guerre donc
les soldats du côté arménien moore au
front sont essentiellement denis en
arménie les armes sont fournies par
l'arménie là vous n'avez pas tout à
l'heure il ya 5 minutes vous n'avez pas
interrogé le ministre de rares ça que
vous avez mis interrogé le ministre
arménien c'est le premier ministre
pashinian qui décident de décide des
opérations donc c'est l'harmonie qui
mène une guerre dans les territoires
azerbaïdjanais pour pour que une partie
des territoires azerbaïdjanais soit
reconnue
nationalement comme un pays à part alors
donc vie ne vivre que des cons minorités
et de la communauté arminia sachant que
les communautés autres corbinien ils ont
été chassés de haut karabagh il ne reste
plus personne à part les arméniens dans
le cadre alors la russie et la france
ont accusé la turquie d'envoyer des
mercenaires pour combattre au karabagh
est ce qu'il ya des preuves concrètes
aujourd'hui selon vous je pense que s'il
y avait des preuves concrètes avant moi
même vous mêmes les services des
services de renseignement des pays comme
la france des états unis de la russie et
autres seront au courant avant tout le
monde
pour l'heure jusqu'à preuve de contraire
aucune preuve concrète n'est présentée
par par aucun pays
à ce sujet il ya eu beaucoup de
d'affirmation il ya eu beaucoup de
didier à ce sujet mais à mon avis
aujourd'hui il y a aucune preuve
concrète
ça c'est une chose deuxième chose il
faut voir cette question nous parle de
vue logique lazare bézian à une
l'armée azerbaïdjanaise a un effectif de
cent mille personnes
pour l'heure il n'y a que trente mille
personnes sur le dock et sont engagés
donc il reste 70 milles réservistes qui
ne sont pas encore engagées et
l'azerbaïdjan n'a pas besoin de dons
sachant aussi que lazard bézian des
arbres et lyonnais ne parle pas la
langue arabe
donc la communication avec cette
personne ces personnes comment comment
il s'est promené créé et pourquoi ces
personnes parce que là quand ces
affirmations dans l'appareil on parlait
de 300 personnes qu environ 300
personnes dans une guerre de cette
ampleur sachant surtout que la guerre se
fait surtout par le moyen d'être daltrey
rider drôme de d'autres donc aujourd'hui
pour les raisons que je viens
d'expliciter à mon sens cette
affirmation
ne quittant pas ne tient pas alors pour
terminer en quelques mots l'arménie
accusent régulièrement la turquie
d'encourager l'azerbaïdjan à combattre
afin que la turquie arrive en position
de force à la table des négociations du
groupe de minsk est ce que cette
hypothèse vous semble plausible
pour l'instant j'en ai aussi entendu
parler
en effet iliad était la situation mais
les rencontres de moscou il ya deux
jours ont démontré que la turquie n'est
pas à la table de négociations il ya un
groupe de minsk
composé de trois pays la france les
etats-unis la russie
pour l'instant ce groupe est d'actualité
la turquie n'a aucun statut de
négociateur et d'intermédiaires ou autre
après il faut aussi savoir que dans
cette guerre et beaucoup beaucoup de
choses ont été dites dont certains
partis la majeure partie s'est avérée
fausse donc j'ai entendu dire qu'il la
turquie et l'azerbaïdjan à l'intention
de commettre un deuxième génocide
arménien mais sachez que avancé conflit
qui a été initiée par les hommes
arméniens du haut-karabakh soutenus par
l'arménie
les arméniens et les herbages année ils
ont toujours vécu ensemble ils n'ont
jamais eu aucun conflit ethnique les
éléments les événements de 1915
les hasards belge année à cette époque
là faisait partie de l'empiré russe et
se battait contre l'empiré ottoman ils
n'y ont pas participé donc l'azerbaïdjan
et les azerbaïdjanais il n'a jamais eu
aucune intention envers les arméniens
autre que libérer leurs territoires
occupés illégalement occupés et il faut
savoir qu'il ya un million de personnes
qui se sont déplacées de ce territoire
vers l'azerbaïdjan qui ont toujours
aujourd'hui le statut de réfugié on
arrive au bout du temps qui nous est
imparti merci dit valdi gasimov pour
vous aux propos anti qui n'engage que
vous bien évidemment je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur en droit international
et spécialiste du caucase et c'est la
fin de cette émission on va se retrouver
dans quelques minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité rester avec nous
la défense
[Musique]
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et et la préparer
il ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire entraîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter 20 à 30% de son
pub pour essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur nous
expliqué qu'effectivement le réveil va
être compliqué il va être douloureux
il ya eu un moment de très grand
relâchement et nous sommes en train de
payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous le numéro i l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose alors jean
francky
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
on est sur des bourses qui se porte bien
alors qu'on sait très bien que
l'économie en général est très très très
très loin derrière les actions ne sont
plus le reflet d'une activité humaine
ce sont de purs objets mathématiques est
ce que cette crise est liée au corps et
dix neuf elle a accentué ce décalage
entre l'économie réelle et les marchés
boursiers sont déconnectés depuis déjà
un bon moment c'est depuis que les
banques centrales ont une politique
d'impression monétaire et ses fameux
quantitative easing
les gérants sont simplement là comme des
joueurs de casino pour affecter le cash
dont il dispose à bas le risque que ça
c'est qu'à un moment on se fait comme
dans les dessins animés ou se réveille
et on s'aperçoit qu'on est au dessus du
lit
[Musique]
la crise du courant d'un virus s'aggrave
en amérique latine la situation est
effectivement c'est cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 max hoarau ni
la gravité de la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon et disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
jeu car nous avons besoin aussi d'être
en paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
le 14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président avait décidé de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pau au moyen orient
certains disent que nous